l'adjointe à la seule chose que je veux
dire c'était que c'était une
intoxication médicamenteuse
je n'accuse personne je voulais juste
dire voilà que j'ai pris peut-être de
médicaments sont fait exprès mais que
j'en suis sorti indemne et finalement ça
me donne encore plus envie de vivre
alors donc au ghana qui vont vous avez
zappé bout il y aura des moyens
bah oui parce que je suis cohérente et
parce que finalement moi ça me fait je
les regardais quand même donc je trouve
que tu as fait un très beau travail
benjamin castaldi est très intéressant
dans le dock l'uefa cause être le côté
cendrillon oui mais moi ce que j'aime
passer en fait c'est quand tu dis le sms
de loana parce que pardon mais il ya un
accident au bord de la route ont ralenti
on filme et ont dit non mais attends
c'est bon je vais appeler le samu
ça va aller mieux mais en fait non c'est
pas parce qu'elle va mieux là qu'elle va
mieux dans l'absolu et je pense qu'en
fait on remet on réenclenche le truc est
d'ailleurs on le voit dans le
documentaire que ça me fait du bien
d'avoir des caméras que voilà la montée
sur le bar est maintenant seul m mais
non mais toi tu a décrété en fait il ne
faut plus jamais rien faire avec loana
non j'ai dit que j'étais amateur ne me
dis pas ça je dis juste que 2,2 après
demain elle peut envoyer le même sms en
disant qu'elle est la liste des changes
en elle elle ça lui arrive d'être
déprimé fait comme beaucoup de gens
sinon c'est parce qu'en fait c'est une
drogue dure pour elle si tu veux et
c'est comme si tu donner à chaque fois
un rail ou injustement lui en
l'occurrence on parle de vrai bonheur de
quelqu'un qui a pris des vrais rails
alors ça oui c'est de la drogue c'est
mal ça fait on arrêtait de télévision
c'est pas de la drogue c'est quelque
chose qui lui fait plaisir et et tout le
monde le dit dans le documentaire tous
ses proches elle se nourrit des lamas
proches à part vous la parole en outre
il vous vous comment ça se passe avec
loana vous l'avez ou pas oui oui alors
là elle m'a dit qu'elle allait très bien
elle a eu un petit coup de blues à
quelques jours parce que là avec nico
ils ont fait le déménagement elle a
rendu les clés et plus du tout à paris
c'est fini donc elle habite avec nico
son patelin walla walla on accorde super
est lensoise bien parfait coup alors on
l a rappelé yves bur tega y paraît oui
alors elle a eu un coup de blues et je
pense que dans son coup de blues
elle avait tellement
depuis des mois sylvie au téléphone
comme donc elle l'a elle l'a appelé mais
instinctivement tu vois dans son coup de
blues et puis après on s'est rendu
compte qu'elle a fait une connerie
d'accord alors mais sylvie est là elles
sont épris lourdement à luanda sur son
compte instagram dans cette vidéo elle
fait des comparaisons entre loana et son
ex compagnon et elle révèle que selon
elle loana serait schizophrène
regardez ludovic n'avait pas du tout la
même maladie que loana mon mari était
bel et bien bipolaire avec une addiction
à la basse évidemment comme tout le
monde le sait la divine mais même avant
de me connaître
quand loana elle est belle bien
schizophrène
je ne suis pas dans son dossier médical
mais c'est moi qui me suis occupé d'elle
qui avec un capital très longtemps tous
des jo voilà donc je ne pense pas que
sheila et envie qu'on pense qu'on
compare ludovic son propre fils un loana
qui est devenu un guichet on sait très
bien que loana c'est quelqu'un qui a des
faiblesses qui a du mal à se défendre
elle à l'autre jour ils ont fait avec
avec l'autre tête de noeud là ils ont
fait un truc non enlever les photos
enlever les photos la sémiologue alors
non mais franchement il la d110 comment
ils n'ont pas honte de s'attaquer à
quelqu'un qui en état de faiblesse
d'ailleurs si vous si on est pas con et
qu'on réfléchit quand vous voyez le
parcours de la tête de noeud conquis
loana a porté plainte et que vous voyez
le parcours de 6 luis ortega
vous voyez bien que ces deux personnes
qui se sont rapprochés de personnalités
en état de faiblesse et qu'ils en ont
profité je veux dire pas sortir de saint
cyr pour comprendre cinq ans il vit à
l'étang facetime silver tega bonsoir
sylvie blanchard cindy déjà comment ça
va gérer fort bien alors je joue bien je
vois que vous n'êtes pas réconcilié avec
loana excusez moi je peux intervenir
oui je suis l'invité oui lodger l année
sur les réseaux sociaux qu'elle voulait
un adversaire là
bah oui on coupe et au revoir
alors alors alors on va voir on n'a pas
le bon bout avec aujourd'hui on voit
juste je terminais andy lau annales vous
avez appelé quand elle est en détresse
il ya quelques jours quelque chose on
s'emballe est que la moisson bat le
consensus attendait qu'est-ce que vous
la dire je voulais dire comme ça que
géraldine avait très bien résumé la
chasse d'hier soir avec où tu es là même
temps alors que sylvie alors oui c'est
papote qui vous appelle ouais alors
alors voilà pris alors non mais donc
irin
donc ça va ça va toujours pas bien entre
sylvie et non mais là si lui et l'autre
l'autre ça y est ils sortent
définitivement de la vie de loana
d'ailleurs loana ne veut plus que on
invite ces personnes sur les plateaux
télé d'accord que ça soit dans les
médias très bien pourquoi il parle
d'elle d'ailleurs elle a laissé un
message je voulais juste le début sur
instagram est les copines avec fred je
ne veux plus que vous parliez d'elle par
rapport à moi c'est une pourriture
je vais pas dire le reste mais en gros
faut arrêter d'inviter ces gens là très
bien alors en attendant pouvait lire le
reste elle est droite pour aller de
retour sylvie oui sylvia la bombe a
alors subi les coups de fil a donc déjà
j'ai commencé par dire que j'ai bien
écouté géraldine ce cas la vie à soi et
l'a très bien résumé la situation
en fait c'est plus de notes en bas nous
a mis pas mis ou collègues je ne sais
qui c'est vraiment d'ordre maintenant
psychiatrique cette histoire et il
faudrait arrêter complètement de
médiatiser quelqu'un
qui est ce qui est très dangereuse pour
bref qu'on nous mêmes
voilà et je pense que géraldine a très
très bien tout résumé et nous on ne peut
plus rien faire
elle ne s'est pas égaré quand elle m'a
appelé avant-hier c'est une certitude
savaient très bien qui elle s'adressait
après ces mois les lourdes
ouais je savais que je suis donc on veut
l'aider elle ne veut pas être était elle
continue à vous à briller moi je suis ok
ok louis a pas de souci elle est lourde
la page des coups de fil qui balayait
c'est toujours la même raison c'est ben
laden
alors oui et non oui est lourde la papa
à l'époque et je pense que quelqu'un
fait je pense que c'est loana qui a
salué ces annonces et papote on ne veut
plus que honteux dia s'exprimer elle
veut plus que cauvin s'exprime dans les
médias vraiment coupé les ponts avec ces
gens là qu'est arrêter les invités de
l'équipe à cette fin cbs que vous avez
également cru mourir ce soir voilà est
bon et on jamais te dire tu sais pas si
j'ai envie de te parler à toi est-ce que
vous avez le documentaire ce soir rmc a
été très très bien fait ce qui a déplu à
loana évidemment le coup ouais on
n'arrête pas de mac ne faut pas que je
parle évidemment dont 11 en tant
qu'acteur le reportage rmc elle est très
très bien fait on est très bien fait et
la soutenabilité en pleine face ça fait
mal et le maillot jaune donne pas bon
mais à ce sujet là benjamin castaldi
la dernière question parce que j'avais
mais voilà je ne cherche pas je c'est un
question rires j'avais bien sûr pour
céder oui est-ce que vous avez revu à
bientôt et vous allez bonne soirée à toi
quand tu vois donc ça va mieux tout les
bombes à eric donc vous allez regarder
bien volontaire bruit c'est vraiment un
très beau documentaire à couper la passe
que la voix les échelons non c'est
vraiment un très beau documentaire
franchement félicitations qui n'était
que ma tâche au juste en tant que
gilbert dette avant qu'on passe mais je
les ai vus oui j'ai pas été emballés
daccan que je trouve que ça manque d'une
idée directrice d'une thèse donc voilà
ça m'a paru un tout petit peu creux non
voilà et nicolas alors moi j'ai trouvé
intéressant fourni mais de l'autre côté
je rejoins un petit peu géraldine c'est
à dire que ça va la maintenir
mais jusqu'à quand le problème c'est que
les lumières vont s'arrêter et puis
qu'est ce qui va se passer derrière elle
va attendre autre chose quand est-ce que
ça va lui faire du mal
bah ça peut pas lui faire du bien non
plus en tout cas ce qu'a toujours dire
ce qu'est ce que c'est passager n'ont
alors moi le conte théâtre amateur et
paris oui le conseil que je donne à
loana c'est que là elle a un projet de
cabaret à faire dans le sud avec nicolas
elle lady est là et là je pense que
c'est une bonne chose pour elle qu'elle
est un objectif bien ça va l'aider à se
reconstruire
donc là je dis à loana maintenant tu te
concentres tu as plusieurs mois pour te
remettre en forme wii et surtout ce que
je veux dire à loana parce que je pense
qu'elle doit nous regarder ce soir et se
poser la question l'autre jour au
téléphone
naulleau annan n'ai pas peur il ya des
millions de français qui t'aime encore
ça c'est vrai tout le monde t'aime ne
t'inquiète pas pour ça concentre toi sur
l'ouverture de ton cabaret au mois de
juillet et tout le monde t'aime
voilà donc ne t'inquiète pas